we are in Paris at a special moment
marking the centenary of the 1918
armistice to end the first world war
there are many other events and
occurrences of that historically
significant period that we could also
recognize now 100 years later because
they represent things we believe worthy
of keeping in our minds I can think of
two that bear directly on the past and
the current life of Columbia University
one is the core curriculum that famous
and unique commitment of the University
to educate our youngest and newest
members into the great texts and ideas
of civilizations as an antidote to the
perceived disintegration of
civilizations resulting from that first
world war the other is the Pulitzer
Prizes which are lodged at Columbia and
we're intended to recognize the greatest
American journalism as well as the best
writing and music of the time intended
to provide models of what we should all
aspire to in those fields but there is
another centenary celebration that is
about to take place that is of special
importance to me because it happens to
be my field of interest and scholarly
expertise and because it is a vital part
of our basic values critical to our
quest for knowledge and central to our
political cultures freedom of thought
freedom of speech and freedom of the
press it was in the spring of 1919 that
three cases made their way to the United
States Supreme Court raising for the
first time since the founding of the
country and the adoption of the Bill of
Rights the question what do we make of
these simple words of the First
Amendment Congress shall make no law
abridging the freedom of speech or of
the press all these defendants including
a candidate for president of the United
States Eugene Debs
in a wave of wartime intolerance had
been convicted merely for speaking out
against the US involvement in that war
although the court did not rise to the
occasion and defend freedom of speech
sadly all of the convictions were upheld
these first decisions set in motion a
now century long experiment in creating
an elaborate jurisprudence of free
speech and Free Press that is unique in
human history and profoundly influential
throughout the world I could happily
speak about this at length indeed at any
length any audience will permit my but
the subject for tonight is not to
reflect on what has happened with the
jurisprudence
of freedom of speech and press my point
now is about knowledge about scholarly
expertise and about how we organize our
minds as we said about understanding the
world what it is what it might be in the
1960s and 70s when the very modern
conception of free speech and press were
finally formed with transformative
decisions like New York Times versus
Sullivan saying that public officials
and public figures cannot sue citizens
for false statements that hurt their
reputations Cohen versus California in
which a young man had the words
the draft across the back of his jacket
and was arrested for indecent language
Brandenburg versus Ohio which protected
a meeting of the Ku Klux Klan
and Pentagon Papers which protected the
Washington Post and The New York Times
in publishing stolen classified
documents of the US government as all
these cases and many others formed our
modern notions about free speech and
free press the United States and the
academic community decided to make this
a field I became one of those experts at
that time now about a half century into
this conception in a century into its
making it is very clear to me that we
need to step back take stock reflect and
where we have come but where we should
be heading this is not just because of
some moment
on the historical calendar a hundred
years it is also because we seem to be
living in a time of historical
transformation a revolutionary new
technical technology of communications
the internet a global economic system
that is poorly understood in its
intricacy and its effects movements of
people across the world at an
unprecedented scale and other forces we
are also at a moment of historical
repetition the national fears that
underlay the extraordinary repression
and censorship represented in these
first cases in 1919 are now resurfacing
in the authoritarian tendencies
seemingly everywhere but certainly in
the United States the central point is
that we can no longer look at something
so fundamental as freedom of thought
speech and press in the same ways as
before at least that's how I see it and
yet I am not completely sure how to look
at all of this differently I have ideas
but it is much bigger than what I know
now and this to me is the reason or a
key reason why the Institute for ideas
and imagination at the global center
Europe in Paris at Reed Hall not only
makes good sense but actually is an
imperative what I see and feel in my
field is I believe seen and felt by
countless others in the university world
and beyond it is therefore a very
serious business that we are undertaking
every one of you will have a somewhat
different story to tell and so will
everyone who comes after us but this
project the Institute for ideas and
imagination is suffused with a very
large ambition it is an undertaking
worthy of one of the greatest
universities in the world and an effort
of great importance to humanity I am so
grateful to mark Mazar I can think of no
better leader and I also feel the same
way about our friend and colleague Paul
Leclerc and our global centers dedicated
leader Safwan mustering what we have
launched today will we hope be seen 100
years from now as having helped to
direct and redirect the never finished
search for understanding and knowledge
we aim to make that quest fresher
livelier more meaningful more alive and
useful and it seems good and right to
put this right here in Paris where so
many similar revolutions of the mind
have occurred thank you all for being
the pioneers of this adventure thank you